my dearest Natalie as I write this
letter it's the middle of the night in
late summer an hour ago you cracked the
equations necessary to power the force
field
he showed me up tonight my magnificent
daughter and I couldn't be happier or
prouder of that I always knew you were
special but never did I follow that the
little girl who taught her stuffed
Nessie multiplication tables who grow up
to master quantum laser mechanics I ever
showed the syndicate that the modified
containment forcefield will be
operational in a month's time and it's
all thanks to you
[Music]
I may be just a doddering old fool
trying to hold on to me by a little
while longer before he loses her to
adulthood but I do see I see this strong
media to wonderful young woman you've
become and I know when the day comes
that I'm no longer with you
going to be just fine
the games will be brilliant because you
are brilliant
my daughter can and will do anything she
wants in design because she's the
smartest woman
pretended to occur pour toujours
I did it papa wherever you are you're
cheering for me